qui a forcé les autorités chinoises à s'attaquer aux problèmes de pollution.
La Chine peut devenir un leader mondial de l'environnement.
Mais le portrait que je vais vous en faire aujourd'hui
est contrasté.
Certains signes sont très prometteurs,
d'autres tendances sont plus inquiétantes
et requièrent notre attention.
Mais reprenons le cours de l'histoire.
J'ai commencé à être témoin de l'évolution verte de la Chine
quand j'étais étudiante en thèse en Chine en 2011.
J'ai voyagé à travers tout le pays pour chercher la réponse à la question
que beaucoup de sceptiques se posaient :
que fait vraiment la Chine pour l'environnement ?
A-t-elle une politique environnementale ?
Quelle politique ?
A cette époque, les données PM 2,5 étaient vues comme trop politiquement sensibles,
et le gouvernement les gardait secrètes,
mais les citoyens prenaient conscience de leurs effets nocifs sur la santé
et réclamaient plus de transparence
de la part du gouvernement.
J'ai commencé à être moi-même témoin de l'évolution de cette prise de conscience,
qui grandissait partout en Chine.
Des magasins ont, par exemple, commencé à vendre ces purificateurs d'air
qui pouvaient filtrer les particules dangereuses de PM 2.5.
Des citoyens ont même appelé PM 2.5 des festivals de musique !
(Rires)
Dans un club de golf à Shenzen, dans le sud de la Chine,
on pouvait voir une banderole soutenant la réduction de la pollution au PM 2.5.
« Soyez sous le par, mais pas en respiration. »
Puis le Bureau de Protection de l'Environnement de Shanghai
a décidé de créer une mascotte nommée comme l'indice de qualité de l'air
pour mieux communiquer sur les données de qualité de l'air auprès des gens.
Je l'appelle Madame AQI :
son expression et sa couleur de cheveux change en fonction de la qualité de l'air.
Cinq ans plus tard, elle reste le visage le plus souriant
de la qualité de l'air à Shanghai.
Et puis, en 2015
l'ancien journaliste de CCTV, Chai Jing,
a réalisé le documentaire « Sous le Dôme »,
comparable au Printemps Silencieux de Rachel Carson.
Et comme Rachel Carson
avait attiré l'attention sur l'impact des pesticides sur la santé,
« Sous le Dôme » a gravé dans la conscience populaire
que la pollution de l'air était la cause d'un million de décès prématurés
chaque année en Chine.
La vidéo a reçu
plus de cent millions de visites en un seul week-end
avant que le gouvernement chinois,
craignant qu'elle n'incite à une agitation populaire,
ne la retire d'Internet.
Mais les dégâts étaient déjà faits.
Le tollé sur la pollution de l'air
a encouragé le gouvernement chinois,
peut-être dans un acte d'auto-protection,
à imaginer des façons ambitieuses de s'attaquer
aux causes de la pollution de l'air
et de beaucoup d'autres problèmes environnementaux,
dont son système énergétique.
Car, en Chine,
près des 2/3 de l'électricité proviennent du charbon.
La Chine a plus de centrales au charbon que n'importe quel autre pays au monde,
près de 40% de la production mondiale,
C'est ce qui a poussé le gouvernement chinois
à déclarer la guerre au charbon depuis 2014,
en fermant les petites mines,
en fixant des limites à la consommation de charbon,
en fermant des usines à charbon produisant autant que la consommation australienne.
Ils ont aussi énormément investi
dans les énergies propres et renouvelables,
l'hydroélectrique, l'éolien et le solaire.
Le rythme et l'échelle de cette transformation
ont été tout simplement bluffants.
Je vais vous donner quelques chiffres pour vous en montrer l'ampleur.
La Chine est le premier producteur d'hydroélectricité
avec un tiers de la capacité mondiale.
C'est suffisant pour que chaque citoyen chinois
alimente pendant un an deux maisons en électricité d'origine hydraulique.
Vous connaissez peut-être le barrage des Trois Gorges
que vous voyez ici.
C'est la plus grande usine électrique au monde,
et elle fonctionne avec l'eau.
En matière d'énergie éolienne,
la Chine possède un tiers de la capacité mondiale.
Ce qui en fait le numéro un mondial, et de loin.
Sur le solaire aussi, la Chine est en tête.
En fait, elle a pulvérisé ses objectifs pour 2020,
qui étaient d'installer 105 Gigawatts de capacité solaire.
Et ceci après que le gouvernement a révisé à la hausse
et plusieurs fois cet objectif,
entre 2009 et 2015.
L'an dernier, en seulement sept mois,
la Chine a installé 35 gigawatts de capacité solaire.
C'est plus de la moitié de la capacité totale installée aux États-Unis.
La Chine l'a fait en seulement sept mois.
Cette croissance remarquable de l'énergie solaire se vérifie depuis l'espace,
comme l'a montré la startup SpaceKnow sur cette image.
En 2020, la Chine devrait produire autant que la consommation électrique allemande
juste à partir de l'éolien et du solaire.
C'est vraiment remarquable.
Et nous pouvons aujourd'hui prouver
que les efforts en matière d'énergie propre
ont un effet réel,
non seulement sur la pollution de l'air,
mais aussi sur le changement climatique,
où la Chine a la plus forte empreinte carbone au monde.
Si on regarde les chiffres, on voit que la consommation de charbon de la Chine
a atteint un pic dès l'année 2013.
C'est la raison principale qui a conduit le gouvernement chinois à annoncer
avoir atteint ses objectifs de réduction d'émissions de CO2 pour 2020
en avance sur le planning.
Cette réduction de la consommation de charbon
conduit également à une amélioration de la qualité de l'air
partout dans le pays,
comme je le montre ici en bleu.
Dans la plupart des grandes villes chinoises
la pollution de l'air a été réduite jusqu'à 30%.
Et cette réduction de la pollution de l'air permet aux gens
de vivre plus longtemps,
en moyenne 2 ans et demi de plus qu'ils ne l'auraient pu en 2013.
En jaune, on peut voir les villes qui ont connu
les plus importantes améliorations de la qualité de l'air.
Bien sûr, comme je l'ai dit au début de mon intervention,
cet optimisme doit être tempéré
par une dose raisonnable de précaution
et ceci en grande partie car les données sont encore à valider.
A la fin de l'année dernière,
après environ trois ans d'analyses poussées sur les émissions de CO2,
les projections scientifiques suggèrent
que les émissions de CO2 pourraient augmenter à nouveau
en raison de la croissance de la consommation d'énergies fossiles,
Le pic que j'ai montré plus tôt pourrait être dépassé.
Mais bien sûr, les statistiques et les données ne sont pas encore précises
car la Chine révise régulièrement ses données sur le charbon après coup.
En fait, c'est amusant,
car depuis que je suis ici, j'ai débattu sur Twitter
avec d'autres experts du climat
pour tenter de savoir si les émissions chinoises de CO2
avaient augmenté, diminué, ou étaient restées stables.
Et bien sûr, la Chine est encore un pays en fort développement.
Elle expérimente encore de nombreuses politiques,
comme les vélos en libre-service sans station,
salués comme une solution potentielle de transport durable.
Mais ces images de cimetière de vélos
dépeignent une histoire plus inquiétante.
Parfois, les solutions avancent trop vite
et dépassent la demande.
Et bien sûr, le charbon est toujours roi en Chine,
du moins pour le moment.
Alors pourquoi se soucier de ce que fait la Chine pour l'environnement ?
En fait, ce que fait la Chine pour l'environnement
peut avoir un impact global pour nous tous.
Pour reprendre une citation de Chai Jing,
nous sommes tous sous le même dôme.
La pollution de l'air venant de Chine
peut voyager au-delà de ses frontières
et toucher des populations aussi éloignées que celles d'Amérique du Nord.
La Chine n'exporte pas seulement sa pollution de l'air,
mais aussi de l'aide, des infrastructures et de la technologie.
Xi Jinping a annoncé en 2013 l'initiative des Nouvelles routes de la soie,
un projet d'investissement en milliards de dollars dans les infrastructures
dans plus de 60 pays.
Historiquement, quand on a vu
la Chine faire des investissements si importants,
ils n'ont pas toujours été propres.
L'Institut Global de l'Environnement, une association chinoise,
a découvert que, ces 15 dernières années,
la Chine a investi dans plus de 240 usines à charbon de production électrique
dans plus de 68 pays
en lien avec les Nouvelles routes de la soie.
C'est plus du quart de la capacité interne de la Chine
qui est exportée à l'étranger.
Donc, on peut voir que même si la Chine fait le ménage chez elle,
elle exporte une partie de cette pollution
dans d'autres pays,
et les gaz à effet de serre n'ont pas de passeport.
Donc quand on essaie de savoir
si la Chine est en tête ou non,
on peut voir que le débat est toujours ouvert.
Mais le temps presse.
J'ai étudié les modèles climatiques et les projections ne sont pas bonnes.
Il y a toujours un écart entre les politiques actuelles
et ce dont nous avons besoin pour éviter de dangereux changements climatiques.
Nous avons désespérément besoin d'un leader
mais il ne vient pas des États-Unis, par exemple.
En juin dernier, l'administration américaine a annoncé son intention
de se retirer de l'Accord de Paris sur le climat,
et les gens se tournent maintenant vers la Chine pour trouver ce leader.
La Chine peut devenir l'acteur-clé
de notre futur environnemental.
Ce qu'ils font sur le négoce de carbone,
sur les énergies propres, la pollution de l'air,
peut nous apprendre beaucoup.
Une des leçons est que l'énergie propre n'est pas bonne que pour l'environnement,
elle peut sauver des vies en réduisant la pollution de l'air.
C'est aussi positif pour l'économie.
L'an dernier,
la Chine a contribué à hauteur de 30% de la croissance globale
des emplois de l'économie verte.
Les États-Unis ? Seulement 6%.
Le portrait que je vous ai dépeint
paraît très contrasté
entre les statistiques sombres de la qualité de l'air
et cette image plus positive des énergies propres en Chine.
Et même si la Chine va dans la bonne direction,
nous savons que le chemin est encore très long.
Alors posons-nous encore la question : Est-ce que voir, c'est croire ?
Peut-on croire les données et les statistiques
qui montrent un effondrement de la qualité de l'air
alors que son combat contre le charbon a un réel impact ?
Regardons quelques images satellites récentes
des installations solaires chinoises.
Regardez attentivement ces images.
Vous voyez ?
La preuve pourrait bien se trouver dans les pandas.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)